Fox News Alert Customs and Border
Protection releasing November numbers in
a Friday night dump Before Christmas
showing a record-breaking 233 thousand
encounters the highest November on
record nearly 67 000 of those encounters
were processed for deportation under
title 42 leaving officials on edge for
the impacts when the policy expires here
to react former acting ice director Tom
Homan Tom Merry Christmas what do you
make of this Friday night dub why do
they wait until the Friday night heading
into Christmas to release these
unprecedented November numbers
Kingdom
well it's obviously okay as you know
they always dump the numbers down like a
Friday night and uh but this time I
really think the reason they they waited
so long to dump the numbers because yeah
I'm gonna spill they did not want the
numbers released before the Congress
voted on Omnibus well it wasn't really
effective anyways because too many
Republicans actually voted for the
Omnibus but I think that's one of the
reasons because these numbers would have
come out maybe a few more congressmen or
Senators would have stepped up and say
look we can no longer take these numbers
this is another record-breaking month we
need to do something about border
security but you know we all know how it
turned out the Omni bus came out with
zero money for border security so that
was disappointing but the barber higher
the numbers that's an important
question of the administration just
because they're so terrible that's an
important part though because there's no
border enforcement money but uh to nerd
out a little bit on page 753 there's 1.9
billion for non-detension Border
management
requirements so what is the two billion
going for
well look it says it says right in the
language of the bill none of this money
is being used for border security
efforts we're in the middle of most
historically immigration crisis ever I
can't believe a single Republican
senator or Congressman to vote for this
bill I mean they all go down the
Southwest border and they do their hit
saying what a terrible crisis we have
it's a national security crisis when it
comes down to making a difference that
they voted for a bill to give nothing to
it so this bill does nothing it lets
border patrol hire up to 300 agents but
boruto can't hurt as it is I mean
portrait Mr hiring point last year
because no one wants a job because
they've been thrown on the bus by the
administration they're working 24 7.
they can't do the job they they were
hard to do they violated the ultimate
because they're not allowed to enforce
the law so boruto is having a hard time
hiring it to begin with so 300 hiring
the money for 300 does nothing for them
time in the first 85 days of this fiscal
year which began on October 1st there's
been more than 575 000 migrant
encounters and that's with title 42 in
place what happens what does it look
like when and if that lifts
look if they left title 42 we already
know give up to up to 80 to 90 percent
of Ages are off the line because we're
dealing with these family groups
therefore if they if taught a fortune
could slip that means more aliens come
across line which means more agents get
pulled off Patrol which means what means
more fentanyl comes across the board
it's going to kill more Americans it
means more suspected terrorists can
cross the border because the border is
wide open and vulnerable it means a
higher sex trafficking of women and
children it it just this is this is
catastrophic and when they end title
four two it's going to get worse but
hear me now that this Administration
really wants to secure the Border they
could try to remain in Mexico program on
today you know I know the main
electrical program program on the Trump
Administration the game changer so if
they want to give the board of trouble
some relief if they want to do some
security in that border restart the
remaining Mexico program they have that
option the federal court says it's legal
and they can do it
well we'll see if they take your advice
and if they change any policies we
learned it's apparently President Biden
was upset and cursing it aids when this
Crisis began in 2021 but yet there has
been no major policy changes to get this
under control Tom Homan as always thank
you for your Insight and have a Merry
Christmas
Merry Christmas to you guys all right
I'm Steve Ducey I'm Brian Kilmeade and
I'm Ainsley Earhart and click here to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis